- Les véhicules à essence
et au diesel se retrouvent
dans le viseur de la COP26.
La représentante britannique
des Transports exhorte
les gouvernements et
les constructeurs à s'engager
à mettre fin à la vente des
véhicules polluants, d'ici 2040.
Une trentaine de pays ont signé
cette entente, dont le Canada,
le Mexique et le Royaume-Uni
En revanche, la Chine,
les États-Unis, la France
et l'Allemagne, parmi les plus
importants pays constructeurs,
ont refusé de le fsé de le fsé .
ANDRÉ BÉLISLE, Ass. québ. lutte
contre pollution atmosphérique
- Ça ne me surprend pas de voir
des pays qui comptent
sur les grands manufacturiers
automobiles pour leur économie
se plier au desiderata honteux
ompagnies-là.
- Six constructeurs automobiles
s'engagent à vendre uniquement
des véhicules zéro émission
d'ici 2040. Il s'agit de Ford,
Volvo, GM, BMW, Jaguar-
Land Rover et la chinoise BYD. r
ces constructeurs qui devront
revoir de fond en
leurs chaines de production,
afin de construire uniquement
des véhicules électriques.triqu.
YAN CIMON, Faculté des sciences
de l'administration, Uni. Laval
- Il faudra voir maintenant
comment les constructeurs
pourront rencontrer le défi
qui sera lié d'abord au prix
et à l'accessibilité
de ces véhicules-là.
"Nous avons besoin de
mesures incitatives",clame la d,
qui demande aux gouvernements
un coup de pouce financier
afin réduire les coûts
de construction et rendreles vés
abordables.
La suppression des véhicules
à moteur pourrait avoir
un effet considérable sur
l'environnement, alors que
le transport routier représente
plus de 10 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
sur la planète.
Ici Jérôme Bergeron,